farm managers series ending employment
although we all hire with the attention
of gaining a great new employee for our
staff sometimes employees are a poor fit
for their positions their work does not
meet your standards their behaviors are
unacceptable or you simply can't afford
to keep a person on your payroll this
module provides a process to end
employment legally and professionally
I'm Pat McCabe and I'll be taking you
through this training at well employment
means anyone can be terminated from a
position at any time without notice and
without cause check that your state is
an at-will employment state please note
you cannot terminate employment if the
reason is due to one of the protected
classes under discrimination laws for
example someone's race color national
origin religion sex age or mental or
physical disability Vermont and New
Hampshire laws prohibit terminating
employment for reasons based on sexual
orientation HIV status place of birth
and age over 18 the laws prohibit
termination as retaliation against an
employee who has alleged employment
discrimination or filed a sexual
harassment or discrimination claim or
who has served as a witness to another's
claim or who has reported an unfair
labor practice or who reported a
violation of a law as a whistleblower
again check with your attorney if you
are considering terminating employment
for the first time even in a state with
at-will employment laws in place it's
best to provide clear feedback to
employees and to document any problems
along the way and to provide your
employees with opportunities to turn
around their work however your decision
may ultimately be to end someone's
employment at the same time at-will
employment allows you to make an
immediate termination for any problems
without a warning if you choose or if
you have no other option
ending employment with dignity can
prevent an unpleasant scene and preserve
your interests as the business owner
remember that it's always painful for
the employee being fired whether they
were expecting it or not it can be
painful for the business owner too but
there are steps you can take to have it
go more smoothly first deliver the news
in private don't wait until the end of
the shift when others may also be
leaving work
try not to deliver the news by yourself
if there's another supervisor have them
join you to deliver the news say as
little as possible don't get into a
debate you may say I hear your point of
view but state that you've made your
final decision be firm and respectful
this simply isn't working out I'm sorry
you can remind them of what the
expectations were for their work
performance remember that we've talked
earlier about why it's important for you
to get to work on time you've already
had three chances to improve your
attendance since you were late again
today I'm letting you go and today's
your last day working here remember you
aren't required to provide a reason for
the termination but they may ask you you
can always say thank you for your work
you'll be paid for the rest of the day
but you should pack up your things and
head home now have the employee fill out
and sign a timecard or record the hours
worked already in the pay period in both
Vermont and New Hampshire any wages due
to the employee must be paid within 72
hours of the termination of their
employment in other states check with
your Department of Labor for the payoff
requirements most businesses find it
easier to provide a manual check during
the meeting if you're laying off an
employee for lack of work you can pay on
the next pay date collect any of your
business property that was issued to the
employee
quis equipment uniforms etc provide a
receipt for those items returns you and
the employee should both sign it include
the final paycheck on the list so that
the employee verifies that it was
received if the person seems upset walk
them to their car or let a co-worker
drive them home
if they are threatening or becoming
violent contact your local law
enforcement if asked agree to only
provide a limited reference to a
potential new employer you should limit
your information to the facts when the
person worked for you and what their
work entailed if the prospective new
employer wants to know why your former
employee left you can always say that
you aren't able to discuss it rather
than disclosing your reasons for
termination good luck and that's the end
of the lesson